of all the political rhetoric that we
have heard and analyzed in recent days
and weeks
I think I've just discovered the
absolute tippy top of the Heap the creme
de La Creme this would be our vice
president Kamala Harris giving a
discourse on Venn diagrams
remember Venn diagrams those three
circles right and then let's just see
where they overlap you will not be
surprised because I have constructed a
Venn diagram on this remember those
three circles how they overlap I love
Venn diagrams so I just do whenever
you're dealing with conflict pull out a
Venn diagram right and so you know
that's recircles and so I so I asked my
team right they're freaking out right
now he sees the Venn diagram of it all
he sees that there are those circles and
maybe people seem that they're a little
different they live in different parts
of the country they may be different age
or different race but that area in the
middle that overlap but I asked my team
to do a Venn diagram of where these
attacks are happening so voting rights
women's Reproductive Rights lgbtq rights
and of course there was a huge
intersection you know I asked my team to
do a Venn diagram for me of where we are
seeing attacks and who are the attacks
against and the similarity and when you
look at a diagram of the uh just a Venn
diagram in that regard it tells a real
Tale
this is the caliber of intellect leading
our country
a third grade caliber of intellect this
is I almost wonder when I watch that
clip
did Kamala Harris just learn what a Venn
diagram is did she or I don't know
what's better that she just learned what
a Venn diagram is or that her education
never progressed past the third grade
because Kamala Harris I guess has a law
degree
but
you know this is typical now of our
education structure we flatter ourselves
we say oh we're the most educated
generation ever oh yes Americans have
more degrees than ever right but we're
we have more degrees but we are much
less educated because those degrees
don't mean anything anymore because all
the standards have been dramatically
lowered for various reasons of national
policy and the decay of these
institutions the standards are much
lower now such that you could have a not
only a bachelor's degree but a law
degree
and this is the height of your political
thinking not exactly metternique okay
we're not talking about tally Rand over
here all right this is where we are and
do not think for one second that that
woman cannot become president
I just I just want to encourage people
to expand their political imaginations I
think I guess that's sort of the theme
of this show
don't believe what the fact Checkers
tell you about the crazy conspiracy
theories don't believe what the
propagandists tell you about the fog of
War
trying to clear up the fog of War don't
believe what the pundits with their own
agendas tell you about oh Trump can't
win or this this person's the only
person who can win
I would not believe any of that stuff
okay
don't believe them when they tell you
Kamala Harris can't become President
John Federman is about to become a U.S
senator all right it said that they said
that no one would elect a guy who can't
speak they did they said no one would
elect Trump they did that woman could be
your next president all right if that's
not enough to motivate you to get out
and help the Republicans win I I don't
know what will there are plenty of
arguments about the role of Maga and
Trump going into the future there's one
really weak argument though that I keep
hearing and actually I heard it from a
guy that I like a lot Nick Mulvaney
was a former well I think it was Chief
of Staff to Donald Trump at least acting
chief of staff and so he was a Maga guy
he supported Trump he was with him but
he says that Trump is probably the one
guy
who could lose in 2024.
do you think this is good for the
Republican party no I I don't because I
think he's the only Republican who could
lose
um if he run if he wins in 2024 now he's
a candidate he is the likely Republican
nominee can he be beaten Head to Head by
Ron DeSantis or Tim Scott sure but it's
not going to be a head-to-head race
there'll be five or six other people in
the race and he'll get the 35 percent
that really support him and under the
winner take all primary system he'll be
the nominee
um but that means the 2024 race is not
about Joe Biden or whatever Democrat is
on the on the ticket not about inflation
not about world events not about
abortion it'll be about Donald Trump the
same thing we saw in 2020. no one voted
for Joe Biden everybody voted for or
against Donald Trump it was a referendum
on him and that's what we're hurtling
towards in 2024 and I don't see the
outcome being any different two years
from now than it was two years ago
so I like Mick Mulvaney I don't think
the guy's a squish I think a lot of his
analysis is quite good especially well I
actually had given the same analysis
earlier in the show I think his analysis
of the way the primaries shake out is
very very good as well if you look at
2016 had Rubio dropped out earlier Ted
Cruz would have been the GOP nominee
it's just it's just the way the
primaries work but because he stayed in
it split that anti-trump vote and so
Donald Trump gets the plurality
plurality plurality eventually he's the
nominee so I think all of that's true
where I think Mulvaney though is wrong
and frankly naive
is the idea that Donald Trump is the
only Republican who could lose in 2024.
I have almost the exact opposite take
I I sort of think that it's virtually
impossible for a republican to win in
2024. I I took a little look at the
election map
okay the Electoral College map here and
I went through
all of the states that Republicans could
win and I was very generous on the
toss-up States okay I said that
Republicans get Florida I said
Republicans get Texas sure I said
Republicans get Ohio I said Republicans
get Wisconsin that's far from certain
but I said let's say Republicans get
Wisconsin I said Republicans get North
Carolina far from certain probably
unlikely but okay let's throw that there
too I said Republicans get Nevada very
far from certain I'm very skeptical the
Republicans will get Nevada but okay
let's say Republicans get Nevada okay
even still
I gave the Democrats Michigan
gave the Democrats Colorado I think is
quite clear at this point even still
with all of that being so generous to
what the Republicans could get
without Arizona the Republicans lose
and Arizona has real problems with the
elections though those Maricopa
voting machines just they just don't
seem to work all that well Whoopsie
Daisy
the people conducting the elections in
Arizona well the the top official to
conduct elections in this past cycle was
Katie Hobbs who was the Democrat who was
running for governor and then
coincidentally won but even you look at
the Maricopa County officials there was
a uh a rejoinder to the questioning on
the right of the the Maricopa elections
and people pointed out they said well
you know the Maricopa County officials
conducting the elections they're
actually Republicans yeah they're
Republican mostly Republicans sort of
except that they hate Donald Trump
they're never Trump Republicans they go
on left-wing news outlets they have been
going on for a very long time lambasting
Donald Trump and the trumpian candidates
and anyone who raises any questions
about the election procedures then you
look at the election laws in Arizona
they heavily favor Democrats and so
I'm highly skeptical that if we can't
tune up these laws that any Republican
could possibly win but the idea that oh
it's only Donald Trump so only Donald
Trump the people give me a break
part of the reason that the other
candidates look shiny right now is
because the national apparatus has not
attacked them yet attacked them to some
degree the scientist has taken plenty of
slings and arrows
but nowhere near the kind of slings and
arrows that we've seen from Trump it's
not desantis's fault DeSantis hasn't run
a national campaign yet
and that's what happens and very often
what will happen is the media will prop
up certain Republican candidates during
the primary campaign only to try to
clobber them in the General in fact
that's exactly what happened with Donald
Trump the media encouraged Donald Trump
they celebrated Trump because they
thought he'd be the easiest to beat in
the general election
then it turned out Trump beats Hillary
the idea I'm not I am not saying with
certainty
the Trump is the best candidate in 2024
I'm far from saying that
but he is far from the worst candidate
Donald Trump helped put together a
coalition
that was different and better
than the GOP establishment coalition
then the Mitt Romney for listen 47
percent of Americans are just
freeloading poor people that remember
that remember that comment
listen we're just going to cut all we're
just going to cut taxes and Outsource
all of your jobs and open up the borders
remember remember that Republican Party
I know I think the Trump movement
inspires far greater support
than uh and the other stuff and yes he's
gotten the attacks sure he's been in the
game for six seven years now
but the next guy is going to get that
too I remember during the primaries in
2016 2015. I was sitting in uh in Los
Angeles at a bar and uh one of the staff
members comes over
and uh this guy was obviously Hispanic I
didn't know if he was legal or illegal
had a very thick accent and uh didn't
ask him and and he's looking and we're
watching the debates and he's kind of
shaking his head at the Canada so I
forget who was on maybe it was
I don't know Ted Cruz I said oh you
don't like Ted Cruz he goes no he's not
my guy
I said oh who do you like
you like uh
Hillary because no I don't like Hillary
oh okay well you like Rubio nah I don't
like Rubio I go through all the
candidates I finally get down to the
last one I said wait
Who Who Are You supporting Trump my man
Trump and I I just
have found again and again
it's not the fancy people at the fancy
DC cocktail parties and the big think
tanks at the fancy lunches or wherever
it's ordinary people working ordinary
jobs that you don't hear about on TV
those are the people who flock to Trump
who did not like other candidates could
a Rhonda Santos win over those people
yeah sure maybe I don't know I will see
if when they run a national campaign but
we know that Trump got them and this
idea that he's always uniquely
off-putting to people I I don't buy that
for one second John McCain was uniquely
off-putting to people he lost Mitt
Romney was uniquely off-putting to
people he lost I guess not uniquely he
just kind of ordinarily off-putting to
people
Donald Trump won those guys lost Donald
Trump one okay so don't tell me about
who who is guaranteed to lose
I will be hosting a panel right now in
the member block
of women
of good-looking normal women from around
the country to explain to me the appeal
of skeet Davidson the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]